Hey traders, this is Mike from Orderflow
here. I'm excited to show you how easy
it is to use the Orderflow Reader AI
app. So, after you've screenshotted your
chart, saved it to your computer, all
you do is you open up the app and you
just click in this box here where it
says to drop your footprint chart here.
So, all you do is you click, you find it
wherever you saved it, click on the
chart, and then you press this green
button analyze. Okay, now the button
won't be green until you actually drop a
chart there, and you can see it's
performing the analysis, right? It's
reading the order flow structure,
analyzing delta, and imbalances, and
more. It's evaluating the bar-to-bar
context and it's going to give you the
final verdict. Now, you know, one thing
to keep in mind is
right, this is a screenshot. So, it's
going to read the most
recent order flow first. You know, why
is that? Because that's the most
important order flow that is being
analyzed. Now, there's another way that
you can use this app is to analyze
trades that you have taken. Okay, I'll
do that in another video. That way it
will show you, you know, what went wrong
for you in the order flow. Sort of, you
know, you you read the order flow, you
took a trade, but different type of
order flow came in that caused the trade
not to work out, right? Or if it was a
winning trade, you know, you want to
see, you know, maybe some other aspects
of the order flow that maybe you missed.
Okay, so now the analysis is done, and
based on where the market is right now
on the far right-hand side with this
current bar, it's telling you it's
bearish, right? Confidence of it being
bearish is quite high, it's 85%. Now
it's doing bar-to-bar comparison. Okay,
now it's looking over the rest of the
previous order flow
to tell you where the bullish and
bearish zones are. Okay, you see bullish
bearish. Current bar position, you know,
if it's broken through some support or
balance, etc. Uh market context is kind
of neutral, right? Which is to be
expected. This market is going sideways.
And
you know, it's telling you the final
verdict is is quite strong bearish,
right? And it's telling you why. Then,
more importantly, what it's giving you
is is the key lessons from the chart,
okay? Things you can learn from this
chart. Stacked where the stacked
imbalances are coming in, why it
matters. Selling absorption at the high,
why it matters. Volume climax and
accumulation, why it matters. Rotational
market structure.
Okay. Anything that's important there,
it's giving you a lesson. So, you know,
what what makes it so useful for you as
a trader is it's telling you what the
important aspects of the order flow are
on that chart. So, you know,
everybody trades a different chart type.
Everybody trades different markets. You
know, maybe you are a nat gas trader.
So, watching a video on someone trading
Nasdaq isn't very useful to you. So, you
want to analyze the markets that you're
looking at, that you're trading. Now,
here's the cool part. You can export
this to a PDF. So, you just click this
button here, export to PDF.
Okay, PDF has been
generated. You know, if I want to open
it up, I just click on there, and let's
bring it in here a little smaller. So,
you can see, see it's a two-page PDF.
All right, with that analysis there. So,
you could print this up, you can save
it, you know, and sort of make notes,
you know, highlight the important
aspects of order flow that you want to
trade in the future. All right, so you
can see how how simple it is to use. One
other thing, you can actually change the
background if you I like the light
background. Some people like a dark
background. You have this sun up here,
that's for the light background. If you
click there, it's sort of well, I'm
sorry, this is the sun, the other one
was the moon.
Okay, so for a light background, you're
going to click on the sun when it is a
black background, but when it's a light
background, you click on the moon to
make it dark. So, very simple, easy to
use. Okay, so thanks everyone, and I'll
see you on the next video.